wenn hier in Stuttgart in dieser Weinbar
Bernd Kreis sind seine Küche geht Herr
stark dienende Lehre eigentlich sollte
hier längst ein Koch aus Peru stehen und
landestypische peruanische Gerichte
kochen weil das Restaurant aber kein
peruanisches Ambiente besitze so die
Behörden bekommt der Koch kein Visum und
darf nicht nach Deutschland kommen es
geht zum Beispiel hier um die Dekoration
in unserem Raum das sei zu nüchtern ein
Spezialitätenrestaurant hat
landestypisch dekoriert zu sein
also das sitzt irgendjemand hinterm
Schreibtisch hier in Deutschland der
entscheidet über peruanische Kultur wie
das auszusehen hat wahrscheinlich fehlt
ihm der Typ mit der Panflöte der
Sommelier Bernd Kreis ist Liebhaber der
peruanischen Küche sie passt ideal zum
Konzept seiner Weinbar hifi.de deshalb
sucht er seit Herbst 2021 in ganz Europa
einen Koch weil sich niemand meldet
versuchte es schließlich in Peru mit
Erfolg ausgebildet an renommierten
Kochschulen und mit weltweiter Erfahrung
in der sternegast Energie passt der
Küchenchef perfekt im Februar 2022
beantragt der Peruaner sein Visum Anfang
Oktober gibt es dann die böse
Überraschung die Qualifikation wird
anerkannt aber nach Deutschland darf er
trotzdem nicht kommen der Grund die
sachlich schlichte Ausstattung des
Lokals lässt kein landestypisches
Ambiente erkennen auf sowas muss man
erstmal kommen
ich finde es komplett Schwachsinn also
man sollte schon wenn jemand arbeiten
will dann soll man den auch arbeiten
lassen das hat nichts mit Dekoration
oder sonst was zu tun typisch deutsche
Bürokratie was anders kann man
eigentlich nicht sagen
so sieht es auch Band Kreis dass die
Arbeitserlaubnis seines Kochs an
peruanischer Folklore hängt macht ihn
wütend
nicht nur in Deutschland in ganz Europa
werden händeringend Leute gesucht
schließen Betriebe weil sie nicht mehr
ihre Arbeit leisten können oder
Schränken eher Betrieb ein und wenn dann
jemand noch einen findet der kochen kann
und kochen möchte dass man den nicht ins
Land lässt dass es unglaublich als ich
der Länderspiegel einschaltet kommt
jetzt plötzlich Bewegung in die Sache
die Bundesagentur für Arbeit teilt uns
schriftlich mit aufgrund neuer
Erkenntnisse haben wir den Sachverhalt
erneut geprüft und sind zu der
Entscheidung gekommen dass der
Gastronomiebetrieb hifidelity in
Stuttgart nun als
Spezialitätenrestaurant bewertet werden
kann das letzte Wort hat jetzt die
deutsche Botschaft in Lima möglich dass
der Koch aus Peru in Stuttgart demnächst
doch noch loslegen kann auch ohne Poncho
und Panflöte